um what do you think about the uh the
hood olympics have you seen this i
haven't seen it yeah you haven't seen
this crazy the crate great challenge
i've seen it on social media are we
allowed to do that during the tour or
should we wait until after because
you guys are going to do it recreate it
now i got to
do you have it up is there a way that we
can get it up it's right here right
there oh yeah oh and you're just trying
to see how you can go on craigslist no
video game watch
hold on here it is
his beard so yeah
they set up like a pyramid of crates and
you just gotta get across if you get
across you get money for it
but it's the funniest thing to watch oh
here we go now this is fantastic this is
the shake on it is amazing
oh yeah yeah okay so right now he's
going for the top crib
and the whole neighborhood is here the
whole neighborhood everyone's gonna know
that he has his shirt off they get 10
feet in the air they're 10 feet in the
air and i guess you get some money if
you don't but these this went [ __ ]
viral kyries are
oh my god look at this portal this is
french fantastic the whole neighborhood
is just dialogue she's laughing oh this
is fantastic so this is going viral like
everybody's doing it everybody's doing
it you guys need to do it soon well what
i wanted to do is
i want to come out to the show on the
crate challenge hilarious so i want the
crates
[ __ ] well i want to have you guys
oh no you can't [ __ ] have a cable dog
i want a cable oh that that's lame i
want a cable now you can't like i do a
[ __ ] show in front of two thousand
people don't do it you can't do a table
no one gives a [ __ ] it's a show business
no i then don't do it
you don't let him do a cable no
yeah i got a cable
ride your motorcycle during the netflix
special that's a good point i didn't do
the motorcycle
oh james dean electric motorcycle with
bicycle pedals
it's an electric bicycle it's electric
bikes or bicycle it's a harley let's not
call it motorcycle it's a motorcycle
it's basically a motorcycle what are you
doing the winner then i put on a little
i put on some mittens
if i'm doing a show shop look at what
happened
look at what happened i don't think any
more athletic in that dude say again
you'll make that here's the thing i
haven't seen anybody it didn't look like
they have like severe alcoholism or drug
yeah there's a lot going on yeah like
come on there was one i saw where a guy
rolled a blunt the whole time i was like
oh this would happen when it's not
crackhead it's like you can do it quite
easily but if you've been doing it
yeah say what then they would have to
come out but give us a second
i want to see mark do it just fall on
his ass and bounce right back
[Laughter]
mario dude yeah
no i think this is what shakarya
richardson has to do what do you mean
that's how she redeems herself she comes
back and masturbates
at olympics and then she gets back in
the regular olympics she's back this is
a redemption art for her and you could
smoke weed and do this then there's no
like
soda or anything like that i don't i
don't think they test no these people
are not sober honestly if shikari does
this she's a legend agree
if shikari does this she's like we can't
hear her we
i think that we got to do it you down i
think i'm too heavy where do you get all
the milk crates that's a good problem
which actually is good that is milk
crazy i think i'm too heavy you think
yeah you think you would crush the
grapes yeah i think i'd crush the crate
what about before steroids
before you put on all this weight what
do you think how much do you think you
put on since you started it's milk
weight right he's just drinking milk
just milk jokes for babies
you don't drink milk no [ __ ] no not
disgusting
i'm
vaccinated you're a vaccinated
anti-vaxxer bro you're a wild boy
you're a wild boy dude you're a wild boy
no comment dog
dude so no milk what else no milk that's
it man
you don't just have a grass of milk
that was good
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay what about a glass
you want to just have a glass of whole
milk or two
no just give up on it
it's over bro
it's over bro
you [ __ ] it up it's over man
come on dude why is chin dodging us what
the [ __ ] is going on here chin's on tour
bro he's on tour the musician him in the
little brows my boy little brows who won
the white rapper contest for king's
thing
he's like blowing up get the [ __ ] so him
and china on tour they're there in
cleveland what are they calling it the
delta variant
bro dude it was crazy when he was on uh
on rogan bro that was wild
when he was talking about escape in
north korea
oh do you believe that yeah you i i love
going on rogan you're like bro you
believe all that [ __ ]
i was like
because i don't believe it either i
don't believe it you're upset at me i
don't believe it either i was just
making jokes about her tits being big
we were like she's stuck she's stacked
she was stacked but but they say she's
like the paris hilton of uh korea of
north korea
yeah yeah
which is i don't know what that is like
i mean it's like hood rich you know but
um obviously i'm sure she saw some crazy
[ __ ] but maybe she's embellishing a
little bit more but i basically went on
there i was like dude
it's like
it's weird to take her word for it and
we can't but here's the thing like if
it's horrible there which we all
acknowledge it's horrible there
just [ __ ] lie and make it seem even
worse so maybe somebody goes over there
and helps i agree like if she goes there
and she's like actually i had it pretty
good in north korea and nobody gives a
[ __ ] about your story you know so it's
like i i almost look at her like like
what we do with jokes like if i have a
story that i tell on stage i'm gonna
exaggerate them it's lies
[Applause]